[Musique]
bonsoir ça fonctionne qu'à alors savez
vous ce que disait confucius à propos
d'une ville on a deux vies la deuxième
commence quand on réalise qu'on emmène
alors imaginons une jeune fille
scolarité impeccable baccalauréat
scientifique diplômés d'écoles de
commerce
elle a 22 23 ans et déjà elle se met la
pression il faut réussir rentrer dans la
compétition s'imposer alors elle se
lance dans le marketing et pendant dix
ans elle va vendre des shampoings de la
mayonnaise des abonnements téléphoniques
et puis progressivement elle se demande
à quoi ça sert
si c'est ça le sens de sa vie elle n'est
pas seule nous avons pu avoir des
exemples ce soir comme celui de soria
est en fait cela concerne tout le monde
cette jeune fille c'était moi j'ai
flirté pendant dix ans avec le
capitalisme avec un grand c et puis
quand ma fille est née je lisais de la
science fiction et je me suis dit
qu'elle ne verrait pas les arbres je me
suis dit qu'il n'y aurait plus de
feuilles aux arbres quand elle serait
grande ma reconversion est venu delà de
cette prise de conscience des violences
qu'ont fait subir à la nature et qui
vont de pair avec la montée des
inégalités car le social et
l'environnemental sont intimement liés
je trouvais que le monde marchait sur la
tête ça ne correspondait pas à ma vision
de la vie il me fallait
car une vision sans exécution n'est
qu'une hallucination
c'est comme ça que j'ai lâché la
publicité pour l'entrepreneuriat social
alors un entrepreneur social c'est quoi
c'est un mix entre richard branson le
flamboyant patron de virgin ils
l'intègrent et non moins impressionnante
mère teresa l'entrepreneuriat social à
la volonté de soumettre la performance
économique au critère de l'intérêt
général
le profit n'est plus le but ultime de
l'entreprise
mais c'est un moyen pour répondre à
d'autres objectifs aux priorités plus
social et environnemental
quand on y pense ce devait être le cas
de tout le secteur économique non
l'entrepreneuriat social recèle de
solutions innovantes de la réussite
éducative à la lutte contre le
gaspillage
c'est un secteur en pleine vitalité
d'une grande modernité d'une grande
humanité
c'est l'économie de demain alors y at il
autant ploie qu'est ce qui caractérise
notre preneur sociale tout d'abord
l'entrepreneur social part d'un problème
non résolu et va construire sa solution
innovante
prenons l'exemple de lagence du don en
nature que j'ai contribué à lancer il ya
une dizaine d'années l'association est
partie d'un double constat aberrant
chaque année en france
les entreprises sont contraintes de
détruire plus de 600 millions d'euros de
produits neufs non-alimentaire parce
qu'ils sont passés de mode yves un
changement le marcou changement de
packaging
à la fin elle est détruite pour faire de
la place dans leur entrepôt alors que
dans le même temps il y a huit millions
de personnes en france qui vivent sous
le seuil de pauvreté et qui n'ont pas
accès à ces produits
c
absurde c'est pour ça que l'association
a créé une chaîne logistique qui lui
permet de collecter ces produits et de
les redonner aux plus démunis moins de
gaspillage pis de partage c'est son
credo
elle a démarré avec quelques palettes de
shampoing et maintenant chaque année
c'est plus de 30 millions d'euros de
produits neufs qui sont redistribués aux
plus démunis
c'est significatif car l'entrepreneur
social recherche l'efficacité et mesure
son impact
il applique le meilleur du privé à sa
mission d'intérêt général
ils utilisent des outils numériques des
solutions innovantes
il est un acteur du développement
économique et contribue à maintenir
l'emploi en france
prenons un bel exemple avec le groupe
arche et à romans sur isère de men in
france économique et social imaginez
romans-sur-isère la ville du savoir
faire français en matière de chaussures
quand le dernier chausseur ferme
quel désastre humain et économique
alors le groupe arche et a racheté les
usines investi dans la formation
employer des salariés en insertion
ils produisent maintenant près de cinq
mille paires de chaussures chaque année
et viennent de monter un partenariat
avec une marque de jeans très tendance
pour lancer une gamme de sneakers enfin
l'entrepreneur social construit son
entreprise sur un mode beaucoup plus
démocratique et participatif avec à la
clé un refus de l'enrichissement
personnel et une volonté de mieux
partager les richesses la valeur crée
d'ailleurs à partir d'un certain montant
de rémunération
cela ne rend ni plus performant ni plus
heureux souvenons nous de deux exemples
emblématiques
la dépression du patron de tesla elon
musk et le regret de steve jobs à la fin
de sa vie et puis franchement dans notre
vie où il ya 3 millions de travailleurs
pauvres
comment pourrait-il y avoir des écarts
de salaire de 1 à 8 cents
c'est une question de bon sens de
cohésion sociale de responsabilité
l'entrepreneuriat social
c'est une philosophie c'est un état
d'esprit
c'est un rêve réaliste avec un enjeu
simplissime changer le monde en un petit
peu mieux
ce n'est pas une question de statut
juridique des entreprises des
associations des coopératives enough de
plus en plus pour l'impact social et
environnemental et vous tous qui être là
ce soir vous pouvez vous lancer vous
pouvez vous engager vous pouvez saisir
votre ticket de chance c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'a fait le fondateur de
l'entreprise vae les deux rives
quand il a découvert par hasard la loi
promulguant la validation des acquis de
l'expérience vient il a trouvé que ce
concept qui permet de transformer son
expérience en diplôme pouvait donner
quelque chose avec deux effets
premièrement mettre un diplôme sur son
cv et on sait à quel point c'est
important dans notre pays
et deuxièmement faire prendre conscience
aux gens de leur compétence de les
nommer d'en parler efficacement et
finalement de prendre confiance en eux
l'entreprise d'ipo maintenant chaque
année plus de 1000 personnes
pas mal non pour une idée qui est arrivé
par hasard alors l'économie sociale et
solidaire au sens large pèse aujourd'hui
quelque 10% du pib
mais il faudrait que ça pèse 90%
il faut inverser la norme il y a urgence
parce que si on continue on pourra plus
continuer alors faire bouger les lignes
changer de logiciel c'est ce qu'on
essaie de faire avec le french intacte
initiative gouvernementale qui s'est
organisé en association loi 1901 le
french impact une bannière une dynamique
pour tous les acteurs de l'innovation
sociale
sa mission c'est de mobiliser les
entreprises
les coopératives les mutuelles les
associations les startups les citoyens
les pouvoirs publics de mettre tout le
monde autour de la table pour résoudre
les grands défis sociaux et
environnementaux de casiers les silos de
caisse et les postures nous pensons que
cette manière d'agir décloisonner qui va
créer de la valeur et nous permettent de
faire sauter les verrous réglementaire
financier culturel
nous croyons au pouvoir de la
coopération
d'ailleurs des solutions innovantes
existent en local comme celle que je
vous ai cités et nous voulons les faire
grandir en faire des solutions
nationales voire inspiré des politiques
publiques
l'innovation sociale et environnementale
est un formidable levier de
transformation pour faire réussir notre
pays
alors la réussite on y revient qu'est ce
que ça veut dire au niveau individuel
réussi pour moi j'ai d'abord agir j'ai
besoin de voir une utilité mon entrantes
mon impact est pour vous est ce que ce
serait assumer ses convictions ses
différences oser comme le disait pierre
avoir de l'audace
oxmo puccino tout à l'heure j'ai en tête
le souvenir d'une femme incroyable haut
fonctionnaire exhortant une assemblée de
hauts potentiels de l'état à être
davantage aware c'est à dire conscient
des réalités terre je vous assure que
pour emprunter cet anglicisme mâchant du
van damme devant un parterre de
serviteurs de l'état en costume foncé
il faut avoir de l'audace et de la
personnalité et samaa son énergie était
communicative d'ailleurs est ce que ce
serait pas ça aussi réussir donner de l'
envie donner de la joie
regardez montpellier il symbolise mon
engagement social et environnemental
je suis enchaîné à la planète eh bien
tous les jours mais tous les jours je
suis arrêté par des sourires des hommes
des femmes des jeunes des vieux qui me
demande qu'est ce que c'est cette chaîne
crée du lien alors comme mon métier
c'est un peu de faire bouger les lignes
un collègue me disait récemment que
j'étais comme un chien heureux dans un
jeu de quilles ce sera ma définition
personnelle de la réussite
et quant à vous rêvez plus grands viser
plus haut
lutter plus fort la vie n'attend pas
[Applaudissements]